I do think in situations when it comes
to abuse and stuff like that I mean it
definitely is not always reported when a
woman is beating a man or like put a
hands on a man but I do think that
sometimes men like in a relationship
women get pushed to a point and then
maybe they'll do something or they've
been I don't know do you know what I'm
saying no no
no I just feel like then you should
leave
but you can't some
eventually you can't leave and then also
I mean but to me that's that's kind of
an excuse like if we reverse the roles
right let's say we reverse it and it's a
man with a woman and maybe financially
like they're splitting the bills 50 50.
like I'm not gonna feel I don't want to
say I will feel bad but like you you
have to take an accountability for the
situation you put yourself in